these kids maybe play-acting but what
they're simulating is highly sinister a
school shooting what should they do if a
gunman storms their classroom and they
aren't able to run away fight back
Sadie's teachers that's what does great
seven classes practicing they've been
taught that together they can overrun an
attacker kids could actually happen and
if it does I don't think it'll be as
easy as in the simulation I'm scared
that in a real emergency things could
happen very differently learning how to
barricade themselves into a classroom is
also an important part of the exercise
students know when they hear a fire
alarm they have to run outside in the
event of an attack it's the exact
opposite that's what trainer hines caft
is trying to make clear he and other
teachers at this High School in western
Germany began these training sessions a
few years ago but classes like this are
extremely rare most schools in Germany
are wary of tackling this topic so
head-on I don't think schools here are
prepared attacks are a taboo subject
there are training sessions for teachers
but generally if there's a reluctance to
train and educate the students mainly I
think because schools don't want to
unsettle them the likelihood of a school
shooting in Germany is relatively low
but that doesn't stop it from being on
these students Minds especially after
the latest tragedy at high school in
Florida could you picture something like
this happening in our school asks this
teacher many here say they could
although they don't feel as threatened
as students in the US
it was pretty crazy what's happening in
the US with the guns and everything it's
definitely very different to here in
Germany I think it's good that it's not
so easy to get a gun here in Germany I
think we probably feel very different
here because gun laws are much stricter
and people can't just get hold of a
weapon critics of these training
sessions say they cause unnecessary
panic but they're going down well with
these students I know it's very unlikely
that anything will happen here but
should something happen we'll know what
to do and that's the best thing the
students can gain a sense of confidence
everybody here hopes they'll never have
to put what they've learned into
practice but knowing they're prepared is
enough to put many of these students
minds at ease